hey guys Pete here the expanse season
four dropped on Amazon and I bench my
way all the way through it there's some
major changes in the way the story
played out compared to the books but
essentially we end up in the same place
that we get to somewhere in the fifth
book so this is just an explanation of
what happened it will spoil everything
that you saw in season four so if you
haven't watched that yet you don't want
to watch this video I've read all the
books that are out and I won't spoil
those but this will be a quick
explanation of where things end up
without spoiling what's going to happen
next
so the expanse has always been a story
about three different factions the earth
Mars and the belt the proto molecule was
created by another civilization which we
don't know a whole lot about but we do
know that they don't exist anymore
something else wiped them out season
three of the expanse ended with the ring
gates opening in season four shows us
the effect that's had on the rest of the
other factions the whole story revolves
around the crew of the Ross and Dante
James Holden is an earther Amos is an
earther alex is a Martian and Naomi is a
belter they all came together you know
the story of how that happened and in
season 4 they're sent by earth to go to
Ellis which is the first planet that's
been inhabited outside of the ring gates
illness itself isn't that important what
is important is the fact that there's
1,300 habitable worlds out there now and
that has the potential to change
everything before we get into how that
changes everything let's talk about what
happens on Ellis with the crew of the
Rocinante there's basically three
important takeaways that happen there
one is that a land grab with all these
different new worlds would be messy and
dangerous we see that be messy because
belters get there first they try to take
over the planet earth sends RCE they
have a legitimate claim and fighting
ensues we see that it's dangerous
because all these worlds are habitable
but they're all different systems where
life was created independently so it's
different we see this with the death
slugs and with the eye infections that
everybody gets and starts going blind
can't just go to these places and not
expect there to be some dangers the next
thing
is that not all belters can actually
move on to a planet just because it has
an atmosphere
I was surprised whenever I saw the
trailers that Naomi went down the well
like it wasn't something that happened
in the books it makes sense now after
seeing that in the season
she's our example of someone who is in
relatively good health should be able to
take the medications and prepare and
then be able to live on a planet it
doesn't go that way and this is
important for all the belters because
there's gonna be this rush to these new
worlds and not all of them can actually
participate the third thing is that
still no one really understands the
proto molecule ring builders who they
were and what happened to them proto
Miller the version of Miller that's
created from the proto molecule is our
bridge with that and he is able to shut
down everything that comes to life on
this planet whenever they arrive but he
does that using the bullet this black
hole thing that's underneath the
structure and that is left over from the
civilization that destroyed the one that
built all the Rings so we don't really
understand what's going on with that but
we know that there is something bigger
than just Earth Mars and the belt and
the people who created the proto
molecule in the end the new character lb
plays a role to help Miller shut off the
proto molecule that destroys him before
that he tells Holden about protein
molecule that was on the Rocinante
that's where he came from the fact that
that active proto molecule was on their
ship was how he was able to manifest so
it is the end of his story as far as we
know for everyone else there some of the
belters stay behind some of the
scientists stay behind LV and fiies stay
there in the crew of the Rossi take off
and leave back through the ring gate all
the stuff that happens on Mars and on
earth is added it's not in the book for
this part of the story most of it works
to get us to where we need to be in book
four Cibolo burn Bobby is the prologue
and Albus our Allah is the epilogue
otherwise we don't hear of Earth because
the area outside the ring gates is
really far away and that's part of the
tension that happens there is that
nobody can just show up and fix things
so the big takeaways from Mars
are that with the ring gates opening
Mars itself really isn't important
anymore Mars was a colony it gained its
independence from Earth because of the
Epstein Drive whenever that was created
there that gave them a technological
superiority so they made a deal to share
that with earth and they got their
independence
they've been on this generational plan
to terraform the planet
now there's 1,300 other worlds out there
they don't need to do that to Mars
anymore and we get this through Bobby's
story we see that people who were in it
for the long haul that were good
Martians are now starting to question
whether they need to stay there anymore
the other big thing here is that
somebody high up in the Martian military
is aiding Marco and helping them get
their materials that they need to set
this plan we see at the end of the
episode in motion we don't know who that
is
at this point but that's a pretty big
deal because Mars was always the
straight shooters the guys who were all
sort of working together for the greater
good of their own planet this is also a
big deal because Mars has a really
strong military the Brasi is a Martian
ship we know that that's advanced and
that plays a big part in enabling them
to do what they do
Mars also has stealth technology which
is ahead of the earth and in general has
a technological advantage as far as
their Navy is concerned although you
remember from the previous seasons that
Earth has more ships so there is a
balance but the fact that those are out
there and someone might get them or
someone might use them against the rest
of the solar system is a big thing to
think about the story on earth is
basically Albus or Allah wants to stop
the gold rush it causes a lot of
problems we have this idea of her being
in a election where her opponent is four
that her opponents for going through the
rings she wants to keep that from
happening because of all the problems
that she can see that could happen and
what we saw happen on Ellis is just the
beginning
her losing the election at the end means
that that expansion is going to happen
and it also takes a Basara off of Earth
and sends her to the moon
the final faction is of course the
belters and we can see here that there
are several different groups inside that
group essentially vying for power the TV
show
move the Marco storyline up but it ends
in exactly the same place how they get
the weapons and the stealth technology
is a little bit different but here they
just use that as a way to show you
what's going on with Mars so at the end
of the story Marco has got his plan in
action he's put stealth technology on
asteroids and he's flung them at earth
this is huge because while everybody's
always been against earth and being
underneath their control it's been
unthinkable to this point to attack the
planet where all life came from he sees
the opening of the gates as an
opportunity not for belters to spread
themselves out through the different
gates and populate planets but to be in
control of things outside of the inner
planets where everyone's going to be
traveling to go through all these gates
so at the end of the season we see that
he's put his plan into motion he wants
to attack earth he has some kind of an
alliance or an arrangement with somebody
high up in the Martian military we have
to imagine that those people know that
he's trying to weaken Earth and that
they're on board for that
the other thing that happens at the end
here is that Astra does die but as he's
being spaced he's able to record Marco
and send that out so that will alert
someone to what these plans are but it's
not clear if there's any way anybody can
stop it remember they used the Sojourner
to run a test to learn about the
capabilities they have for their
defenses on earth so they're launching
these asteroids or throwing these rocks
based on the data that they already have
about that so we don't really know about
how long it's going to take
if earth will be able to detect them
what they can do in response and whether
or not his message will help that in any
way ah the solar low has lost her power
she's no longer in charge earth is going
to be moving forward wanting to expand
through the ring gates Mars is going to
lose population people are gonna flee
from there they're also gonna travel
through the gates and try to build new
colonies and new worlds through the
Rings and of course we know that
something built the Pro 2 molecule the
proto molecule went out into the
universe and built the ring gates which
are essentially wormholes that connect
really far away places together and then
we also know that there's something else
that destroyed that civilization who
the proto molecule and that is what the
setup is season four is a big setup
season everything that I talked about
here will be important for later there's
basically two big story arcs that follow
after this one of them concludes in book
six and then the last one is still
playing out as we wait for the last book
to be released the way they did this
season five could get all the way
through books five and six I think
depending on how they break things up I
think once we get there that will make a
lot of sense
as far as how they decided to bring
Marko into the story a little bit early
one of the big things you have to keep
in mind here is that Philip is Naomi's
son Marko is her ex-lover we saw her
talking to Fred trying to find him and
we know that he was present on Mars and
he was present there with his dad
whenever they killed Ashford so that's
gonna complicate things for the crew of
the Rossi and since I don't want to
spoil anything that's gonna happen I
won't talk about any of the rest of what
happens with them but you can imagine
they're gonna be in the center of
everything as they are with all the
stories in the expanse universe and I
think it was a pretty good season I
enjoyed it hope this video is helpful to
tie everything together after watching
it I'm not a big fan of binge series I
like to watch week to week but this is
the way they're gonna do it I'm gonna
still watch the show I like it I can't
wait till the next book comes out so let
me know in the comments what you thought
did you like watching it as a binge show
do you think they did a good job now
that they move to Amazon do you think
this is a good adaptation of book 4 in
parts of book 5 you like the decisions
that they made if you like the TV series
I would highly recommend the book series
just like anything you get a lot more
out of the characters you get different
point of views and things are a lot more
layered in general I think this has been
one of the better adaptations I've seen
they have consolidated characters I do
have some questions about where drummers
character is going after this since
she's a combination of a few different
characters from the book I'm hoping that
we'll see more Fred Johnson if you're
missing him there I think where there's
a good possibility we'll see some more
of him in the next season and I think
that's about all I want to say because I
really don't want to spoil anything for
people who haven't had a chance to read
ahead yet
Miller's ending was pretty good it
seemed like in the book we had more
of him than we do here but I like the
way they handled his ending and as I
mentioned there when he tells them to
remove the proto molecule that should
for all intents and purposes based on
what we know mean that we won't see
Miller again throughout the series
Holden has something going on with him
obviously because he was in the station
and he made that circuit LV would also
have some kind of a connection at this
point because she went through the
bullet the black hole thing that's on
Ellis but all of that still pretty
mysterious so those are the kinds of
things that we have to keep reading and
keep watching to find out about please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you want to
see other videos like it thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon